[Music]
and breaking tonight the sage is south
central
larry elder our friend is entering the
california recall election against gavin
newsom
here with reaction radio talk show host
larry elder
uh leo 2.0 torelli is on for a special
reason no no i got a new hat
i got a new hat what is the hat set i
can't see
i'm hannitized i'm hannah ty's
what about elder size where's he how
about elder
i this surprised me i i had no idea you
were thinking about this
sean leo i'm as shocked as you guys are
i was first approached
to do this several months ago by my
radio colleague dennis prager by people
like jack hibbs
of the calvary church people like lionel
chetwyn who's a
longtime filmmaker and i said hell no i
said this this place is ungovernable
you have super majorities in the
assembly super majorities in the senate
and of course a left-wing governor
we have rising crime rising homelessness
a rising
cost of living and leo knows exactly
what i'm talking about because he's a
former public school teacher
the declining standards of urban schools
so i said forget about it but the more i
looked at it the more i saw how
arrogantly this governor has handled the
pandemic
imposing the most strict coronavirus
lockdowns of any of the 50 states while
violating them at that french restaurant
with the very people that set down the
mandates while his own kids still
enjoyed in school private education
while his own business that winery was
exempted from the mandates something has
to happen and so i decided to jump into
this race
and i want people to go to elect elder
dot com elect elder dot com because he
has
no limits on how much money he can raise
and spend but we do i cannot win this
race unless people from california
and outside california contribute money
so please go to elec
elder dot com uh wow
leo have you made up your mind who
you're supporting caitlyn jenner is in
the race
i interviewed kayla let me oh what what
i mean i'll be very clear i have made it
very clear with all due respect to the
other
candidates i have not endorsed any of
those candidates
larry represents principle and i'll tell
you right now that recall petition could
not exist
without democrats who are upset with
gavin newsom
right last year was the first time i
wanted to leave la
county i wanted to move because it was
horrendous here and it's horrible
gavin newsom needs to be recalled larry
elder is the best
candidate to replace gavin newsom it's
not even close
hands down on the issues of homelessness
education
school choice uh eliminating regulation
it's not even close
and i think that larry elder is the best
candidate well
i'm hannitized larry the hardest part of
the recall though is this you got gavin
newsom bribing people you have gavin
newsom
you know the hypocrite you've got gavin
newsom changing trying to get the date
earlier before the wildfires and the
brownouts
and the state is a hard blue state
will question one is the hard one that's
the recall vote will we get to question
two
i think so as leo pointed out 2.2
million people signed the petition that
recall this guy
and many of them were democrats many of
them were independents the very people
that voted for him two years ago
now tell you something else we have
private ballots so you can go into your
the privacy of your mail-in ballot or
your voting booth
and close the curtain and vote for a
republican you don't have to tell your
friends
you can be an independent and democrat
do you like the crime do you like the
homelessness
do you like the fact that the cost of
living is causing young people to leave
the state
for the first time we've had a net
migration out of california if you're
not happy about that
go to elect elder.com that's elect
elder.com let's get this guy out get
some common sense in sacramento
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else